(upbeat music)
(brand sizzles)
Ever tried a DIY project and found yourself yelling,
"D-I-why did I try this?"
Do-it-yourself expert, Jenni Yolo, has some helpful tips.
You're gonna wanna dip it in, brush it off a few times.
We're gonna start in this corner and go at a 45-degree angle
and start our dashes.
I like to stay close to the line
but not necessarily hit it,
that way you won't get a cutoff dash.
Okay, it looks really good.
Not perfect, but that's what you want.
And now I'm gonna do the other side.
So I like to match up so it creates almost an arrow.
All right, one down,
and I'm gonna finish the rest of the wall now.
We're gonna skip this one that we used as a guide
and this one's gonna be the new center of our arrow
so we'll start going down on this side
and then we'll do the reflection on this side.
And now we're done.
Now we're gonna pull off the tape.
(pleasant music)
The painted wall treatment is done
and I brought everything into this room.
I just love how the design ties it all together.
Great tip, Chip and Joanna.
Where can we watch more Jenni?
Well, she hosts the Handcrafted Home Projects Workshop
on the Magnolia app where you can learn
how to make unique items for your home.
Oh! D-I-why not?
(Chip laughs)
(upbeat music)